pas moins de toi qui tu es tout tu viens
tu peux me dire ton nom je me souviens
de rien la toile nouveau on est arrivé
c'est quoi cet endroit dia venus au bloc
qui nous a envoyés ici on sait pas
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière
vous croyez que je vais rester enfermé
ici je t'interdis pour sauver pourquoi
vous me dites pas ce cas là dedans
celle labyrinthe
tous les matins quand les portes
s'ouvrent
et coureurs s'engouffre pour trouver la
sortie
personne n'a jamais survécu une seule
nuit dans le labyrinthe
qu'est ce qui leur arrive on les appelle
les griffes heures
on n'a rien à faire ici la bia menthe a
bien été construit par quelqu'un c'est
le moment de savoir contre qui on doit
se battre
il n'est pas comme les autres tu es
curieux c'est quoi ce truc c'est le
premier véritable indice que vous
trouvez on sait pas où ça peut nous
conduire
c'est une fille
tout a changé depuis tu déboîté chez
nous peut-être qu'on nous a envoyés pour
une raison précise
les portes se ferment plus qu'ils sont
là
ils vont revenir pour nous massacrer
jusqu'au dernier on va se battre pour
sortir même si on doit mourir
t'as pas capté on est déjà mort
tu es sûr de ton cou avant
on peut passer par des îles nous
empêcherons